the week leading up to Halloween this
only feels appropriate
um and my Halloween dies review I call
it Halloween dies not because evil died
that night but because a franchise did
but when reviewing the retcon that's
part of the recent retcon not the retcon
that happened before that retcon it's
easy to get tunnel vision there but I
saw this comment in the comment section
where someone said Halloween one two and
H2O is their preferred Trilogy their
preferred Canon and I was like
what a good idea that's worth talking
about so sit back relax let's talk about
the original Michael Myers retcon
Halloween H2O
thank you
in another videos where I've mentioned
Halloween H2O I always see that comment
like why are you calling it water it's
H20 or Halloween 20 years later but nope
if Epic movie trailer voice Don
LaFontaine says it is then it is that is
the philosophy I live my entire life by
it only helps me when it comes to movie
titles but all the same I get it is
weird though right oh H Halloween 20 20
years later
water why not so Halloween H2O is the
original Michael Myers retcon it came
out 20 years after the original
Halloween which is 20 years before the
40-year retcon that came out in 2018
Halloween H2O is closer to the release
of the original Halloween than we are to
Halloween H2O
feel old with me my friends feel old but
where's the 2018 Halloween wiped out
everything except the first Halloween
and Halloween three that could still
happen this one wipes out everything
after Halloween too
and yes Halloween 3 could still happen
the point is Halloween four five and six
wiped out never happened so it's
Halloween one two and H2O so that's a
difference here with this retcon
Halloween H2O keeps Halloween 2 which
introduced the lore that Lori Strode and
Michael Myers are brother and sister so
that's still in play for H2O my brother
killed my sister wish I love like that's
a thing that sets H2O apart from the
2018 Halloween this is actually a lot in
H2O that was like they
2018 did that also but H2O did do it
first Laurie Strode tormented by her
pass and in the end she faces Michael
Myers happens in both movies and this is
Halloween springboarding off of Scream
the scream culture which is actually
really interesting or at least funny
gives me a chuckle the fact that Scream
1 mentions Michael Myers Halloween
the one with the guy in the white mask
who walks around and stalks babysitters
and in Halloween H2O they're watching
scream 2. that's breaking the fourth
Wall's fourth wall I don't think it's
too far-fetched to see that scream
flavor in Halloween H2O I mean what
scream did was rejuvenate Revitalize the
slasher genre but it was really cool now
to have your killer be a normal person
who just lost it which is essentially
what Michael Myers was in the beginning
so it all fit to be like yeah let's take
him back to what he was in the beginning
that's actually a really cool thing to
do now
let's do it and the Lori Strode Michael
Myers brother sister connection you see
in this movie it's a thing that this
movie actually heavily revolves around
it's a thing that the new movies just
didn't have you get a very different
flavor with the two films there's
something haunting about Lori Strode
being a functioning alcoholic because
she's traumatized by this past event but
this past event wasn't necessarily
random it's in the family so it's not a
possibility that Michael Myers is going
to come back it's almost a certainty at
that point that's fear on different
levels you know there's an anxiety with
Michael Myers possibly coming back but
he's not related to you but there's a
fear of certainty that this guy is
definitely going to come back because he
wants to kill his entire family and I'm
part of it but I do feel Halloween H2O
feels heavily edited most of the people
who die in this movie either die off
screen or off camera sounds redundant
but what I mean is they either die in a
scene that's not being shown on screen
right there they're dying in another
room entirely or they're getting stuck
stabbed off camera and you just hear the
sound effects but you don't see them
dying in any of those cases though you
do see the aftermath you know you see
jgl with a big old skate through his
face see that horny pervy kid dead in
the little elevator really it was Lori
strode's boyfriend which is the only one
I can actually think got a full stabbing
while the shot was on him and he
convulsed it's actually one of the more
violent deaths in the movie though one
of the least bloody it's like they had a
caveat like you can have a lot of blood
as an aftermath or you can have someone
convulse and die with a knife going into
them but not as much blood you can still
have blood also side note that's actor
Adam Arkin I say that because I legit in
the movie theater thought he was George
Clooney looks to me like they were
trying to play up the tension in this
movie over the gore and I will say that
there's some solid moments of tension in
here I don't always want to have my cake
and eat it too but in a horror movie
where I feel like the scenario is you
can have tension and Gore you can have
your cake and eat it too I'm missing one
I feel the loss also has some pretty
iconic Halloween movie moments you know
Halloween movie imagery in this one
movie the scene where Michael Myers and
Jamie Lee Curtis are staring at each
other through that door window seeing
when Michael Myers is coming down from
the ceiling with one hand I mean dude
it's a pretty badass moment I mean he
gets smacked in the shoulder with an ax
immediately after that but it's still a
sweet scene and this was the first movie
that should I give a spoiler spoiler
warning for the I'll talk about spoilers
now that it matters movies literally 24
years old a spoiler warning is like a
condom better to have it not need it
than need it not have it so spoiler
warning you have been warned Michael
Myers was dead I know they wrecked
conduit in the most [ __ ] way possible
for Halloween resurrection but this is
the movie I was like there's no coming
back from that but if you end it here
for this stretch of movies this Trilogy
this original retcon is pretty
fulfilling I like the fact that Jamie
Lee Curtis for the last act you know
busts the glass gets the fire ax but
this time
it's going to be a fight to the Finish
20 years before it would be this
revolutionary idea in 2018. I guess I'll
break down the continuities like this if
you watch Halloween 1 in 2018 that's
actually a good one-two punch it's a
good start and sequel that's also the
ending and that's where it ends it's
actually pretty satisfying but Halloween
one two and H2O I think is a better
Trilogy than the new Trilogy which is a
little unfair because the new Trilogy if
you're looking at the story as a whole
the whole Arc is a quadrilogy but my
point there is Halloween 1 2 and H2O is
more focused more concise and more
fulfilling than the new movies were but
all in all Halloween H2O is a fun time a
solid Halloween movie it's a retcon that
justified its retcon by giving the fans
a fulfilling conclusion to Lori strod
and Michael Myers but most importantly
it knew what it was it knew it was a
Halloween slasher flick be a Halloween
slasher flick also the Halloween h2o's
credit and I always try to give credit
to this when a movie threads the needle
and does this right it's about 90
minutes long that's perfect and I think
H2O is a great time no alcohol required
all right so Halloween H2O have you seen
it what did you think about it or how
does this stack up to the new retcon
what's your favorite Halloween movie
timeline you can just say three
that's fair but whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]